djokovic on se retrouve dans un nouveau
type de vidéo intitulée christiane times
bon je sais que c'est un titre vraiment
nul à chier plutôt original seulement
j'ai pas eu d'autres idées aujourd'hui
ont versé plus tard alors vous l'aurez
deviné c'est dans ces épisodes quest ix
dame que je répondrai à vos questions
donc là étant donné que j'ai pas prévenu
que j'allais faire cette vidéo je vais
répondre à 10 questions que me pose très
très souvent la première question
pourquoi comment l'as tu commencé les
vidéos alors j'ai commencé les vidéos il
ya deux ans et demi parce que j'avais
énormément d'acné et à cause de cette
acné moi j'étais terriblement complexé
et je me suis mis à jouer énormément
beaucoup plus qu'avant jeu vidéo du coup
je me suis dit bon là tu joues au jeu
faudrait peut-être que voilà que tu
fasses quelque chose peut-être que les
gens peuvent apprécier sans forcément
que tu te mets forcément tout de suite
être bloqué par ton physique ou quoi et
puis je me suis lancé c'est pour ça que
je montrais pas mates et au début puis
j'ai osé montrer ma tête parce que vous
demandiez énormément pour mais sans
bonnet j'avais une vidéo spéciale pour
ça et puis finalement pschitt a tué ou
m'avait donné confiance en moi ou tout
simplement m'avait fait comprendre que
le physique c'était pas une chose
importante dans ce monde là et c'est
comme ça que j'ai commencé les vidéos
c'est pour ça que je vous invite à ne
pas vous moquez de vos camarades qui ont
de l'acné
parce que ça leur salaire renferme tout
simplement sur eux mêmes et ça les
complexes et voilà c'est vraiment pas
que voulait faire ça aux jambes alors
deuxième question est ce que brett est
ta petite amie alors oui gwan est ma
petite amie depuis maintenant presque un
an et
je salue mon père maintenant troisième
question avec toi tu fais tes montage et
quel est ton micro alors je suis le
montage avec sony vegas pro 12 mon micro
c'est une frite moi qu'est-ce qui a
convoyé pas mais je vous promets une
frite
justement on dispose et joyon se trouve
pour une vidéo intime de ces petits
veaux quatrième question quel est ton
parfum broulis oui on m'a déjà posé
cette question oui
[Musique]
cinquième question quel est ton
déodorants oui je sais que ça va vous
choquer mais je pose cette question
vous pouvez répondre aussi un tout
simplement sixième question c'est quoi
la musique qu'il fait j'ai également
ouaga gigot java giga ouaga ii
chacun dans my hand oui je sais c'est un
nom de merde oui c'est une question
comment tu as fait pour avoir des
abonnés alors étrangement je sais pas
trop comment on peut poser cette
question il n'y a pas forcément
d'astuces pour un dé à mener j'espère
maintenant je suis là mon 18 n inquiète
pas deuxième question far as tu des
rencontres abonnés alors il faut savoir
qu'il ya une loi française qui interdit
en fait de bon je sais pas c'est quoi la
loi exact je ne suis pas avocat mais je
sais qu'en tout cas cette loi dit qu'on
n'a pas le droit de faire des
regroupements de plus de je sais plus
combien de personnes
ou alors faut que ce soit encadré et
c'est pour faire une demande à la
préfecture je sais plus trop quoi donc
la rencontre abonnés elles vont tout
simplement se faire à des événements par
exemple à la paris games week est la
japan expo à tous ces salons et puis bah
si vous me voyez là-bas n'hésitez pas à
venir me voir il n'y a aucun souci je
vous accueillerai les bras couverts
alors 8e question est ce que florence
est ton frère
alors non à vrai dire c'est un gros sdf
qui squattaient madiot le petit con et
oui c'est un gars comme moi
[Musique]
il a aussi invité mon côté réagi alors
10e et dernière question aussi étrange
qu'elle soit
comment tu fais pour tous coiffés comme
ça alors étrangement m'envoyer cette
question quand j'ai vu cette question
pas mal de fois revenir dans vos
messages etc
et puis à écouter aujourd'hui voilà ça
mais ça me pèse mais bon voilà je vous
adore je vais vous dévoiler un petit
secret de famille comment se coiffer
comme squeeze prendre le gel bachelot
gel sur vos marques
tvo demain mettre le jeune homme aux
cheveux en une serviette frotter et
mettez tout simplement du gel dans votre
main et vous vous coiffer les cheveux en
l'air envoyez moi vos questions à notre
escapade à l'écran qu'elle soit de pulp
sérieusement tout quoi que ce soit
n'hésitez pas à m'envoyer je ferai une
sélection de ji souvent question pour le
prochain épisode
en tout cas vraiment sage et vous avez
en quelque sorte changé ma vie en
suivant est aussi nombreux vraiment je
fais des choses que je n'aurais jamais
pu vivre manger des expériences de
malades et tout ça c'est grâce à vous et
je tenais vraiment encore une fois vous
remercier parce qu'on ne fait pas assez
souvent je trouve et c'est important
voilà que vous sachiez que bah voilà on
lui doit tout ça et on aime vous la
faire ce qu'on fait on aime faire
plaisir à des gens leur faire passer les
bons moments en quoi après des journées
de mer par exemple avec cette pluie de
merde mais chose comme ça et puis voilà
juste restez comme vous êtes vous êtes
vraiment top comme je dis tout le temps
et puis à bientôt de la stasi pis on
active
didier porte secrète 1 les chevaux il
était chauffeur salut
boîte premier chez les enfants oui dans
un manoir mois stage là là j'étais juste
à leur place
la gauche